he is the radio analyst for the Los
Angeles chargers and his move the sticks
podcast with Bucky Brooks and then FL
Media Group is must listen he's Daniel
Jeremiah how you doing DJ I'm doing
great what's going on rich great
baseball last night huh no I you know
what it's it's I was basically saying DJ
that that baseball needs to take the NFL
replay model which is to tell a manager
it's not reviewable too bad and not go
under the headsets to double-check a
rule and on top of it make the umpires
announced to the crowd what the hell
they're seeing and what ruling they're
making and then just move on yeah a
little bit a little more efficient there
I get that but man the drama in these
games has been outstanding with the road
team winner all these games nuts I know
we haven't we've never we've never seen
it before let's turn our attention to
the to the trade deadline in which Aqib
to leave at address I mean if I told you
the Dolphins would acquire a player as
the only major trade if you will on a
deadline day I'm sure I could have
knocked you over with a feather why why
so little movement based on your your uh
your telling well I think probably
because we had so much movement before
the deadline you know when you have the
Tunsil trade which was huge you have to
make a fitzpatrick trade you have the
Jalen Ramsay trade I mean if those all
happen on trade deadline we're beating
our chests and saying man the NFL trade
deadlines is right up there with MLB
with all of its excitement but all those
big moves can already took place so
there was a lot of discussion a lot of
chatter but a big fat nothing burger
yeah I know and what where the Jets
relied look I know you don't speak for
Joe Douglas you just hear you're friends
with him and but he was front and center
yesterday that Jamal Adams was on the on
the block and levy on bail was as well
Joe Douglas went on on michael cassio in
new york to say he wasn't shopping them
he was just listening what was happening
there best you can tell yeah I think
it's it's a pretty normal situation
where you kind of say who is untouchable
on your team and he's you know Sam
Donald the quarterbacks untouchable
you've got a young guy that you believes
the future at that most important
position outside of that you listen so I
mean it's not he's calling team saying
hey what do you what do you give me for
Jamal Adams he gets a call from the cow
they put together what we know I read
was an offer of a first-round pick which
was not nearly enough to part with
somebody like that but you kind of gauge
the value of your players but the fact
that he doesn't that he didn't trade
these guys tells you what their value is
and I think that's just being a
responsible GM I I listen to Joe's press
conference yesterday and I haven't had a
chance to talk to him but he said look
from where I'm from you people call you
listen and he didn't mention the name
but where he's from this Adi Newsom
that's where Joe spent over a decade
learning from him my opinion the best in
the business the difference I would say
is that in the Baltimore market versus
the New York market this becomes a much
bigger story well I mean certainly when
its players like Jamaal Adams were then
tweeted out that he told the team last
week he wanted to stay and now and and
basically put it out there that he felt
played you know I'm paraphrasing that
but that that's I mean he basically said
the GM went behind my back and shopped
me around two teams Douglas told Michael
Kay on on the radio I don't take that
personally I mean it doesn't care to me
that this this has got to be a Humpty
Dumpty trying to put it back together
situation wouldn't you think well I mean
you saw the other name mentioned was
loving on bail and you saw his video
last night and so you know him and Joe
had already had a discussion and Le'Veon
Bell is completely on board so I know he
mentioned that he had not talked with
him all Adams I'm sure have a chance to
kind of explain the situation and and I
would imagine that Jamal wound up
feeling differently once he hears how
everything took place but yeah look
that's you get you know it's business
man it's it the NFL is a game but it's
also a business and you know I
understand how players and get upset and
I think that's just a conversation
that's going to take place between four
twenty two grown men and and everything
will smooth out be fine I mean look rich
this team was any good had any wins I
don't think you'd see the frustration
level quite where it is right now really
from the owner all the way down to
arguably your best player Daniel
Jeremiah
here on the Rich Eisen show what makes
the Patriots defense so damn good in a
way that we've never seen it like this
TJ well I was talking to I was talking
to a GM about this year today and we
were trying to come up with it and I I
think they only have two players on
their defense that you would consider
top five at their positions and and
that's what's incredible to me is
gillmore's a top-five player and you got
McCourty two safeties a top-five player
outside of that it's just a great
testament to guys you know playing
exactly where they're supposed to be in
the exact same leveraged position that
they need to be and then it's just
there's nowhere to really go with the
football it's it's it's incredible and
they change it up a little bit I know
they you know the zero pressure look
against the Jets they don't do that
every single week that heavy but they
just they find a way to get it done and
it's it's tremendous tremendous coaching
huh I was having a conversation with
somebody else too today we're talking
about the Patriots and why don't people
emulate the Patriots and what they've
done I said well they don't I mean
everybody talks about you know Brady and
Belichick well you don't have Dante scar
neck yeah for one and you don't have
Belichick for - I mean that would be the
two people that man they are so so sound
and what they do it's it's impressive
let's go Nicki you're talking about what
what did what exactly is it the game
planning and thinking whatever he has
yeah taking whatever players he has and
not putting them in positions that they
can't succeed in other words if you've
got somebody that lacks a little bit of
athleticism through technique and
through help you're able to cover that
up whereas you watch all these other
teams and they've got one weak link and
it's that weak link gets exposed week
after week that never happens with the
Patriots no matter who's out there they
find a way to put these guys in a
position to only do what they can do
well then you go to the Sunday night
game and and John Harbaugh out of the
AFC if you want to look at it I mean the
most success in the biggest spots that
anyone in the AFC has had against the
Patriots you'd have to have Circle
Harbaugh at the top of that list an
extra week to prepare for this game how
do you do they have the weaponry and the
the ability to game plan and change
things around in Game two to take down
the Patriots Sunday night hand them
their first loss otherwise if they don't
I think the Patriots have the 1 seed
pretty much damn near sewn up now it's
gonna be an awesome awesome game and
I'll say a couple things here number one
where as you know a lot of teams get
intimidated by the Patriots not only are
the Ravens not intimidated by the
Patriots they almost relish playing
against the Patriots even though it
hasn't always gone their way I haven't
been in that building for those for some
of those games like it was something
that they really really look forward to
and they felt like they could really
punch them in the mouth and see how they
responded to it so they're not going to
be intimidated John Harbaugh is record
prime time games I think they've won 10
straight
they've been phenomenal there and then
you know Brady is not totally dialed in
right now he usually kind of finds his
ways you get to the season even though
they're winning all these games he's not
playing his best football so you kind of
add all those factors up I think
absolutely the Baltimore Ravens have a
good shot to win this game and the other
point would be the RET the entire thing
is gonna pay attention to what Bill
Belichick does schematically to try and
slow down and stop Lamar Jackson and
this rushing attack which is on record
pace for the Baltimore Ravens I'm
fascinated to see what they're gonna do
there well I wanted just before moving
on to what's going on with the Chargers
and their offense having moved on from
Ken Whisenhunt just touch on the Brady a
comment you just made cuz Kurt Warner
our buddy tweeted out an hour ago saying
it's almost shocking watching the
Patriots offense right now so out of
sync looks like a struggle every game
and visible frustration can be seen over
and over what's so different
conceptually right now they have talent
but it seems so difficult can't quite
put finger on it says Kurt Warner who's
watching that film was so you two are
kind of saying the same thing what it
what are you saying yeah I mean I guess
we're it's different words to say the
same thing I just there's no there's
they're not in rhythm at all and some of
it to me is just their inability to win
one-on-one matchups when they get them
and that was the beauty when you had
somebody like Gronk who you had a
one-on-one winter you've got element
who's a one-on-one winner right now
there's just not really a lot of
separation so I like to when you're
watching the tape kind of freeze the
freeze the tape when Brady gets the top
of the drop and kind of see okay what
does he have available to them and
there's not really getting a lot of
separation that's why to me my theory on
them is you know we've seen what they've
done with James White who basically is a
wide receiver they line up in the
backfield and teams try and match him
with linebackers and it's a joke
so it's manipulating a little bit of the
position of a player I think once they
get Nikhil Harry back you're gonna see
them kind of use their big receivers now
with Mohamed Sanu and Akhil Harry I
think you'll see them start bunching
those guys up and then teams are going
to treat them like wide receivers even
though they're darn near the size of
tight ends and you're gonna see them
just start mulling corners in the run
game and they're gonna try and run it
down people's throat to another Super
Bowl Daniel Jeremiah here on the Rich
Eisen show and Aaron Rodgers and that
offense with Matt Lafleur at the
controls and Aaron Jones and Jamaal
William they're doing it without Davante
Adams who they get back this week and
normally you would say the way to
prepare to try and go point for point
with the Packers is not to replace the
offensive coordinator mere days before
and yet that is what has happened with
the Chargers what what what gives with
letting Whisenhunt go and who and what
happens now well I mean I as a scout
like one of the one of your roles or
whatever is to be perceptive right and
I've thought of myself that I was that I
did a pretty good job in that role well
I had breakfast with Ken Whisenhunt on
Sunday morning before the game against
the Bears and sat for 30 minutes and I
had no idea any of this was was
potentially happening so in terms of
some people and what were the signs did
you see it coming I just I did not I had
no idea that was coming I mean that the
you know if you just look at kind of the
factors I think the the lack of a run
game especially the last four weeks you
know that's something that's that needed
to get corrected and I guess you know
coach Lin felt like that change needed
to be made to try and get better in that
department but yeah I did not took me by
surprise so what what are we gonna see
what who's taken over and
and what's the offense how is it gonna
be any different yeah well Shane
Steichen is gonna call the call the
plays who's who's the quarterbacks coach
is really really one of the bright young
coaches all right the guy who had that
role before him was getting Nick Fury on
e who's the OC now with the Colts and I
think you'll see him be a head coach
soon I think Shane's really really sharp
so he'll take over kind of coordinate
the passing game and calling the plays
and they'll go through the offensive
line coach Coach Meyer to do these to do
the run game and let's be honest I'm
Anthony Lin um you know expertise is the
run game so I would imagine I have not
talked to him I would imagine that he'll
have a pretty good se and then put their
on I'm trying to get this run game up
and going against the Packers this week
in a couple minutes I have left with you
Daniel Jeremiah why are why is Chris
Brockman coming in here every single
week it seems and telling me that
there's a mock draft involving the 2020
draft and Joe burrow is mocked above to
a being taken out why is this is there
is this for real what's going on right
now I don't I think look nobody's helped
themselves more than Joe Burrell has
this year and I watched him over the
summer and I've watched their first
couple games so I've got to do a lot
more work on him but I think he's
definitely got himself into the first
round mix I you know I thought there was
a pretty sizable gap between tua and him
it would take a lot for him to surpass
tua in my mind and I've talked to a
bunch of guys that have been to both
schools on the scouting tour and I
haven't talked to anybody yet they would
say they would have borough over to uh
but they would say all will admit look
nobody's helped themselves more than
than borough he's playing great right
now who was getting hurt affect that do
you think last couple seasons I don't
think yeah I don't think so I mean
really I don't even didn't even miss a
game I think he got hurt and the SEC
championship game last year right and
ended up coming back healthy yes a play
on it helps had a month loss that
doesn't happen in the NFL what 100
percent well he just did the same exact
injury and now they have a bye week but
that would look like it's he's gonna
miss one game so even if you didn't have
the bye week your message you're talking
about one or two games so when it's all
said and done on the sheet it's going to
show that he missed two games in two
years which
you know I don't I don't know that's
necessarily gonna ding him too much and
then you know our our sisters or
brothers at bleacher report are Matt
Miller put out a mock draft just today
with the Bengals being first overall
taking to a what put some pieces
together from that along with what we
just saw with Andy Dalton getting
benched yeah yeah well look and and
everything I've heard I'm talking to
people around there was that this is not
really anything other than about Andy
Dalton's contract and knowing that
that's you know a such a decision that
they need to make at the end of the year
and they want to find out what they have
in Ryan Finley
first and foremost give him the rest of
the season to start see what he can do
and see if they need to go get their
quarterback because I'll tell you what
rich if somehow you can you know Ryan
Finley were to you know just play lights
out and show you that maybe he can be a
gardener meant you type that way over
plays is draft position and maybe we can
move forward with him boy there is a
pretty pass rusher in the big tent you
can go pick up that would be a nice
addition to the spangles teams in the
state they need it this is an audition
oh my gosh that dude is unbelievable
chase yeah so yes yes
just give me a few seconds on him how
unbelievable he's got some he's got some
miles Garrett type you know freakiness
to him when you talk about some of the
freaky guys up there at the top of the
draft we've seen so he's got a totally
different body type than the nikkor door
Joey
I don't you know Nick Bose is the best
leverage pass rusher I've ever seen he
was the best player in the draft last
year hands down yeah I thought it was
was obvious chase is just different he's
taller he's longer he's got a better get
off he's fantastic I mean I why an NFL
team rich has not gone to Larry Johnson
the defensive line coach at Ohio State
and offered him the bone is beyond me
I'd be I would I'd give them the GPS I
took go to Columbus to go find him I
would be more than happy to provide that
information
[Laughter]
think about your Jets real quick you
know your jets for a second let me let
me ask you a question let you be the let
you be the GM okay and see what you
would do in this situation okay yeah
your offensive line
terrible as you know if you're picking
up there say you're picking one two or
three and chase young is there you have
no edge rushers either this is a
fantastic player right you take chase
young or do you take a king's ransom to
slide back a couple picks and then start
addressing Alfred sublime what do you do
I take chase young I do not pass on
somebody generationally talented like
that no way and I certainly if Tom
Brady's gonna sit there as a forty
three-year-old give him something to
think about and somebody in this
division that gonna have to go get him
how does that sound Daniel that's my
answer
that sounds great let me tell that to
your friend you can have your your your
cake and eat it too no just get the
first overall pick and then you put it
up for auction between the two teams
behind you the Bengals and the Dolphins
who you know are both taking
quarterbacks you slide down one or two
spots you get extra picks you get chase
young and that's very holy hell I told
the Jets a month ago tanked worse than
the Dolphins that's the way you beat
your rival is it's trying to take you
take worse than them and go to sell to
the highest bidder the player that they
wanted I'd love it you take care
yourself DJ can you send out will you
send out do me one favor is Jets end up
with the first pick will you send up
thank-you cards I will you got a DJ you
take care yourself you got it move the
sticks for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app